Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Today's episode deals with a crime committed against a child that won't be suitable for all listeners. During recess and to lunchtime at Hackham West Primary School in 1982, teachers patrolled the school yard to oversee the young children as they ran around and played together between lessons. Yet there was often one student separated from the others, preferring to stick by her teacher's sides rather than go off and play with her peers. Ten-year-old Louise Bell.
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序或我们网站上的本集节目说明。今天的节目涉及针对儿童的犯罪，并不适合所有听众。在1982年哈克姆韦斯特小学（Hackham West Primary School）的课间休息和午餐时间，老师们在学校操场上巡逻，监督低龄儿童在课间跑来跑去、一起玩耍。然而，常常有一个学生独自站着，不与其他人合群，她宁愿紧紧跟在老师身边，也不愿去和同龄人一起玩。十岁的露易丝·贝尔（Louise Bell）。
A shy and timid girl, Louise found comfort in the company of adults whom she knew and trusted. When her fifth grade teacher, Miss Grace, asked if Louise would rather play with her classmates instead of accompanying her on yard duty, she responded, I'm fine, I'm happy, I just want to stay and help you, before linking hands with her teacher. Louise's introversion extended beyond school hours. When her friends were rushing out of the classroom to head home, Louise would often stay behind and help clean up before her parents arrived to pick her up. During a school camp, she sat by herself on the bus and didn't interact with the other pupils. But the camp itself served to bring Louise out of her shell. When she joined
作为一个害羞、胆小的女孩，露易丝在自己认识并信任的成年人陪伴下找到了慰藉。当她的五年级老师格雷斯小姐（Miss Grace）问露易丝是否愿意和同学们一起玩，而不是陪着她值日时，她回答说：“我很好，我很开心，我只想留下来帮您，”然后拉住了老师的手。露易丝的内向不仅表现在上学期间。每当朋友们冲出教室准备回家时，露易丝经常会留下来帮忙打扫卫生，然后才等待父母来接她。在一次学校营地活动中，她独自坐在公交车上，没有和其它同学交流。但这次营地活动本身却让露易丝走出了内向。当她加入
in on a pillow fight that broke out amongst the children, the teachers were delighted to see Louise jump in on the fun. It was a clear sign that Louise was finally starting to feel more at ease with her peers. Despite suffering from asthma, she joined the school's basketball team, the year five basketball Saints, donning a number seven blue and yellow jersey. Her father, Colin Bell, sometimes assisted with the team, affording the dad and daughter some valuable bonding time. In late November 1982, the basketball Saints celebrated the end of the season with a breakup barbecue and pool party at their coach's house. During celebrations, Louise was thrilled to be awarded with a trophy commending her efforts, ending 1982 on a high note.
孩子们中间爆发的枕头大战时，老师们很高兴看到露易丝也加入到了欢乐中。这是一个明显的信号，表明露易丝终于开始对同龄人感到更加自在了。尽管患有哮喘，她还是加入了学校的篮球队——五年级篮球圣徒队（basketball Saints），穿上了7号蓝黄相间的球衣。她的父亲科林·贝尔（Colin Bell）有时会协助球队，这让父女俩有了一些宝贵的增进感情的时间。1982年11月下旬，篮球圣徒队在教练家举行了分手烧烤会和泳池派对，以此庆祝赛季结束。在庆祝活动中，露易丝很高兴被授予奖杯以表彰她的努力，为1982年画上了圆满的句号。
The following year started like any other for the Bell family. Parents Colin and Diane were enjoying spending quality time with Louise and their younger daughter, six-year-old Rachel, who were both off school for the summer holidays. Christmas and New Year had gone by in a whirlwind of excitement and social engagements, and things were starting to quieten down after the busy festive season. The Bell family were looking forward to relaxing over the weeks ahead before school resumed at the end of the month, with the two young siblings eager for upcoming plans that included a shopping excursion, a picnic, and a trip to the cinema to see the latest Steven Spielberg blockbuster, ET.
对于贝尔一家来说，接下来的一年和往常一样开始了。父母科林和黛安（Diane）很享受与露易丝以及他们的小女儿、六岁的瑞秋（Rachel）共度美好时光，这两个孩子当时都在放暑假。圣诞节和新年在兴奋和社交活动中转瞬即逝，在忙碌的节日季过后，一切开始平静下来。贝尔一家正期待着在月底学校开学前的几周里好好放松一下，两个年幼的孩子也满心期待着接下来的计划，其中包括一次购物之旅、一次野餐，以及去电影院观看史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格（Steven Spielberg）的最新大片《E.T.外星人》。
On January 4, 1983, Colin and Diane instructed their two daughters to prepare for bedtime as the sun began to set over Meadow Way, a quiet residential street in the lower middle-class suburb of Hackham West. Located 30 kilometers south of Adelaide Central Business District, the Bell residence was an unassuming small family homestead typical of the area. A single-story, cream-brick building with a fenced-in backyard and small front lawn that faced directly onto the street. At 8.30pm, Louise dressed in part of the new pajama set she had received for Christmas, a pale yellow, sleeveless cotton top dotted with small yellow flowers. She chose not to wear the matching shorts as she found them too uncomfortable.
1983年1月4日，随着太阳在Meadow Way（哈克姆韦斯特这个中下阶层郊区一条安静的住宅街）徐徐落下，科林和黛安嘱咐两个女儿准备睡觉。贝尔的住所位于阿德莱德中央商务区以南30公里处，是一座朴素的小型家庭宅基地，也是该地区的典型建筑。一栋单层的奶油色砖房，带有一个带围栏的后院和一个正对着街道的小前院。晚上8点30分，露易丝穿上了她圣诞节收到的一套新睡衣的一部分——一件淡黄色、无袖的棉质上衣，上面点缀着黄色小花。她选择不穿配套的短裤，因为她觉得太不舒服了。
The young Bell daughters said goodnight to their parents and retired to the small bedroom they shared at the front of the house, which held two single beds pushed against adjacent walls, separated by a chest of drawers. The bed heads lay underneath a large window that overlooked the front lawn. At 10.00pm, Diane went to check on her daughters and found that Louise was still awake. Noticing that the curtain and window were open above Louise's bed, Diane instructed her eldest daughter to close them before wishing her goodnight and heading off to bed in the room next door. Diane awoke at 6.00pm the following morning of January 5th. As she walked down the short hallway towards the front door, she peered into her daughter's bedroom and noticed the youngest
贝尔家的小女儿们跟父母道了晚安，退回了位于房子前部、两人合住的小卧室里。房间里有两张单人床，紧靠着相邻的墙壁放置，中间隔着一个抽屉柜。床头位于一扇俯瞰前草坪的大窗户下方。晚上10点00分，黛安去查看女儿们的情况，发现露易丝还醒着。黛安注意到露易丝床铺上方的窗帘和窗户是开着的，便嘱咐大女儿把它们关上，随后道了晚安，去了隔壁房间睡觉。第二天早上6点00分（1月5日），黛安醒了过来。当她沿着短走廊走向前门时，她往女儿的卧室里瞥了一眼，发现最小的
Rachel was still sleeping, but Louise was not in her bed. She checked the lounge room, kitchen, bathroom, and backyard, but there was no sign of her eldest daughter anywhere. Diane woke her husband, Colin, who rushed into his daughter's bedroom where he made a horrifying discovery. The curtain and window above Louise's bed were open and the mesh fly screen appeared to have been cut from the corner of the window frame and was flapping in the breeze. He raced outside, checking the neighbour's swimming pool before heading down the street to the primary school, desperately searching for any sign of his daughter. Failing to find Louise, Colin returned home, distressed to find she hadn't shown up during
瑞秋还在睡觉，但露易丝不在床上。她查看了客厅、厨房、浴室和后院，但到处都找不到大女儿的踪迹。黛安叫醒了她的丈夫科林，科林冲进女儿的卧室，在那里有了可怕的发现。露易丝床头上方的窗帘和窗户开着，窗框角落处的纱网似乎被割破了，正在微风中飘扬。他冲到外面，查看了邻居的游泳池，然后顺着街道朝小学跑去，绝望地寻找女儿的踪迹。没有找到露易丝，科林回到了家中，发现女儿在
his brief absence. He turned to his wife and said, that something is terribly wrong. Police arrived at the Bell's Meadoway property to conduct a search for Louise and question her family about her possible whereabouts. Six-year-old Rachel Bell, who had been sleeping soundly in the bed next to her sister, hadn't heard Louise get out of her bed at any time throughout the night or morning. Likewise, neither of her parents had heard a sound, despite their bedrooms being separated only by a very thin wall, and both bedroom doors remaining open all night. Notably, the window leading into the 10-year-old's bedroom was in
他短暂离开期间并没有出现，这让他感到十分痛苦。他对妻子说，情况非常糟糕。警察赶到了贝尔位于Meadoway的房产，对露易丝进行搜查，并就她可能的去向盘问了她的家人。6岁的瑞秋·贝尔一直在姐姐身旁的床上安睡，在夜间或早晨的任何时候都没有听到露易丝下床的声音。同样地，她的父母也没有听到任何声音，尽管他们的卧室仅隔着一堵非常薄的墙，而且两间卧室的门整晚都开着。值得注意的是，通往这个10岁女孩卧室的窗户
full view of the street, shielded only by a handful of sparsely established trees and shrubs. Other than the tear in the mesh fly screen covering the window, there were no signs of forced entry or of a struggle having taken place. Upon initial inspection of the torn screen, police believed the wire had been pushed out of place from inside the bedroom. This led them to consider the possibility Louise was responsible for the breakage herself, and had likely left home on her own accord and would soon return. However, given Louise's asthmatic medical history, they proceeded with a full-scale investigation amidst concerns for her safety. By 11am, a team had gathered at the nearby
正对着街道，只有几棵稀疏的树木和灌木遮挡。除了窗户上的破损纱网外，没有强行闯入或发生搏斗的迹象。在对破损的纱网进行初步检查后，警方认为铁丝是从卧室里面被推开的。这让他们考虑到一种可能性，即露易丝是自己弄坏的，并且很可能是自愿离开家的，不久就会回来。然而，鉴于露易丝的哮喘病史，出于对她安全的担忧，他们还是展开了全面调查。上午11点前，一个团队在附近的
Christie's Beach police station to formulate a plan, enlisting the services of various departments, including high-ranking police officers, the special task and rescue force, country fire service, and the state emergency services. They established a police command post at the nearby Hackham West Primary School, where Colin Bell made a brief appearance, telling the media, We love Louise very much and want her to come home. It doesn't matter if she's done anything wrong, just some knowledge that she's alright would be a relief. We are worried that she may have an asthma attack if she is in trouble.
克里斯蒂海滩（Christie's Beach）警察局集合，制定搜救计划，并调动了各个部门的力量，包括高级警官、特别任务与搜救部队、乡村消防局以及州紧急服务局。他们在附近的哈克姆韦斯特小学建立了一个警察指挥所，科林·贝尔在那里短暂露面，对媒体说：“我们非常爱露易丝，希望她能回家。她做错了什么都没关系，只要知道她平安无事，我们就会感到宽慰。我们担心如果她遇到麻烦，可能会引发哮喘发作。”
Three helicopters swept the nearby coastline as law enforcement, volunteers, and Louise's relatives and friends combed the surrounding suburbs, checking everything from stormwater drains to rubbish bins. The possibility that the young girl had simply run away from home was dismissed, when over 100 members of the multiple emergency service departments failed to uncover any sign of Louise after six hours of intense searching. By the next day of January 6, police declared Louise's disappearance a major crime. The police technical services team was unable to find any scientific or physical evidence to
三架直升机掠过附近的海岸线，执法人员、志愿者以及露易丝的亲友们搜寻了周围的郊区，从雨水渠到垃圾桶，每个地方都仔细检查了。当100多名来自多个紧急服务部门的成员经过6个小时的紧张搜查仍未发现露易丝的任何踪迹时，“这名年轻女孩只是离家出走”的可能性被排除了。到了第二天1月6日，警方宣布露易丝失踪案为重大刑事案件。警方技术服务团队未能找到任何科学或物理证据来
suggest Louise had been abducted from her bedroom, leading investigators to maintain the belief that the young girl had voluntarily left home, but had ran into foul play shortly thereafter. Rachel Bell drove around with police to point out all the locations that her older sister was known to play, but there was no sign of Louise at any of her favourite hangouts. Police stations across the state were issued with a description of Louise, who was approximately five foot tall and of average build, with short brown hair, brown eyes, lightly freckled skin, and was likely wearing floral yellow pyjamas, but may have taken a change of clothes with her.
表明露易丝是被从卧室绑架的，这导致调查人员依然坚持认为这个年轻女孩是自愿离家，但在那之后不久遭遇了不测。瑞秋·贝尔坐着警车四处指认她姐姐常去玩耍的所有地点，但露易丝常去的那些地方都没有她的踪迹。全州的警察局都收到了露易丝的体貌特征描述：她身高约五英尺，身材匀称，留着短棕色头发，棕色眼睛，皮肤上有淡淡的雀斑，失踪时很可能穿着黄色碎花睡衣，但也可能随身带了一套换洗衣服。
Investigators conducted door knocks of the area and interviewed anyone who had been in recent contact with the Bell family to see if they could uncover any leads. In the days before Louise's disappearance, the local milkman recalled having to jump some tent wires that had been sitting across the concrete path leading to the Bell's front door. However, on the morning of January 5, he noticed the tent wires were no longer sitting on the front path, but had instead been bunched together and moved aside on the lawn, clearing the way. As the search for Louise gathered pace, Colin and Diane Bell remained at home in case their daughter reappeared, where any news came through. Although police had initially advised the couple
调查人员在该地区挨家挨户进行排查，并采访了所有近期与贝尔一家有过接触的人，看能否找到任何线索。在露易丝失踪前的几天里，当地的送奶工回忆说，他不得不跨过几根横亘在通往贝尔家前门混凝土小路上的帐篷绳。然而，在1月5日早上，他注意到这些帐篷绳不再横在前面的小路上，而是被扎成一束移到了草坪的一旁，道路被清理干净了。随着对露易丝的搜寻进度加快，科林和黛安·贝尔留在家中，以防女儿重新出现或有任何消息传过来。尽管警方最初建议这对夫妇
not to speak to the media, in a bid to raise awareness, Colin and Diane invited members of the press into their home to make a public appeal for information. They said they hadn't been able to sleep, spending many hours with police going over Louise's photographs, school reports, and anything at all that might provide some sort of clue. Sitting solemnly on the couch in their lounge room, an emotionally distraught Colin Bell broke down in tears as he told TV news reporters, I'm convinced she's not hiding anywhere, and if someone is watching this, don't harm her, please don't. Diane sat by his side, visibly shaken as she timidly asked her daughter to
不要接受媒体采访，但为了提高公众意识，科林和黛安还是邀请了记者来到家中，向公众公开呼吁提供线索。他们说自己一直无法入眠，花了很多时间与警察一起翻看露易丝的照片、学校成绩单，以及任何可能提供某种线索的东西。科林·贝尔神情黯然地坐在客厅的沙发上，情绪崩溃，泪流满面地对电视新闻记者说：“我确信她没有藏在任何地方，如果有人正在看这个节目，请不要伤害她，求求你们不要。”黛安坐在他身旁，明显受到惊吓，她胆怯地请求女儿
please come home. Colin urged residents of South Australia to check their backyards, sheds, and unoccupied shacks for Louise, before pleading, quote, to anyone who might have her, even if they just leave her in a phone box a hundred miles from here. Please do it. If they fear this has gone too far and don't want to get caught, please don't harm Louise. Leave her where we can find her. A large publicity campaign was launched with hundreds of posters featuring Louise's photograph and the physical description distributed throughout suburban shopping centres, with newspapers, television, and radio stations asked to promote the campaign.
请回家吧。科林敦促南澳大利亚州的居民检查他们的后院、棚屋和空置的小屋，寻找露易丝，随后恳求道：“引述原话，致任何可能带着她的人，哪怕只是把她留在离这儿一百英里外的电话亭里。求求你们这样做。如果他们担心事情闹得太大而不想被抓，请不要伤害露易丝。把她留在我们能找到她的地方。”当局发起了一场大规模的宣传活动，在全澳各地的郊区购物中心分发了数百张印有露易丝照片和体貌特征的海报，并请求报纸、电视台和广播电台协助推广这项活动。
Posters of Louise's smiling face were plastered on the front of public transport buses throughout the Adelaide metropolitan area, urging anyone with information to come forward. 10 detectives were assigned to work on the case full-time, as an additional 35 police officers conducted numerous searches around the Bells property and the surrounding Hackham West area. The police technical services team conducted further tests on the mesh fly screen from the Weezer's bedroom window, and stated they were unable to determine whether the screen had been torn from within the bedroom or cut from outside the home. Police staged a re-enactment to determine the logistics of someone reaching in the bedroom window and snatching Louise from her bed, and
印有露易丝灿烂笑脸的海报被张贴在阿德莱德大都市区公共交通公交车的车身上，敦促任何知情者挺身而出。10名侦探被指派全职负责该案，另有35名警官在贝尔家周围及哈克姆韦斯特周边地区进行了多次搜查。警方技术服务团队对韦瑟（Weezer）卧室窗户上的纱网进行了进一步测试，并表示无法确定纱网是从卧室里面被撕破的还是从房屋外面被割破的。警方进行了一场情景重演，以确定有人伸手进卧室窗户并从床上劫走露易丝的后勤可行性，并
concluded it would have taken an adult male perpetrator six feet tall or higher, just 30 seconds to lift the child and carry her out. They also theorised Louise may have been enticed to exit the house, either via the window or even the front door, although her parents dismissed this theory, saying their daughter was well aware of stranger danger. The Bell family and investigators who were working tirelessly on the case continued to hold onto the hope that Louise would be found alive, but braced themselves for the worst. Major crime squad detective G.J. Edwards said, There is always hope, but as time goes by that hope must diminish.
得出结论：一名身高六英尺或更高的成年男性行凶者只需要30秒就能抱起这名儿童并将其抱出室外。他们还推测，露易丝可能是被诱骗离开房子的，无论是通过窗户还是通过前门，尽管她的父母驳斥了这种理论，称他们的女儿非常清楚陌生人的危险。贝尔一家和夜以继日调查此案的调查人员仍然抱有一线希望，希望露易丝能活着被找到，但也做好了最坏的打算。重案组侦探G·J·爱德华兹（G.J. Edwards）表示：“希望总是有的，但随着时间的推移，这种希望必须减弱。”
The sad part is we just have nothing on how she left home. There is no positive information which could indicate the circumstances of her leaving home or what has happened to her since that time. On January 12, one week after Louise vanished, the South Australian government offered a $5,000 reward for anyone with information about her whereabouts. The reward was not as substantial as the community had hoped, but given the lack of evidence to confirm without question whether or not a crime had occurred, it was the best the government could offer. Acting South Australian Premier, Mr Wright said, You don't know what's happened to this poor 10 year old girl, whether she has run away from home
令人悲伤的是，关于她是如何离开家的，我们一无所获。没有任何确凿的信息能够指出她离家时的环境，或者她自那以后发生了什么。1月12日，在露易丝失踪一周后，南澳大利亚州政府悬赏5000澳元，征集任何关于她下落的线索。这笔悬赏金并不像社区所希望的那样丰厚，但鉴于缺乏证据来毫无疑问地证实是否发生了犯罪，这是政府所能提供的最好的方案了。南澳大利亚州代理总理赖特先生（Mr Wright）表示：“你不知道这个可怜的10岁女孩发生了什么，她是离家出走了
or is lost in a bush. We will increase the reward the moment the police are able to tell me they are now convinced there is a crime, but at present we want information on the whereabouts of the child. The day after the reward was announced, Colin Bell received a phone call. The unknown mail caller claimed to have taken the wheeze and demanded $30,000, threatening to kill the child if the money wasn't paid. The call was soon determined to be a hoax. The caller identified as an unemployed 19 year old from the nearby suburb of Mitchell Park, who was charged with the crime of demanding money with menaces. A second phone call from someone claiming to have information about the wheeze was
还是在丛林中迷路了。一旦警方能够告诉我他们现在确信这是一起犯罪，我们就会立刻提高悬赏金额，但目前我们想要的是关于这个孩子下落的信息。”悬赏发布后的第二天，科林·贝尔接到了一个电话。这名未知的男性来电者声称自己带走了韦瑟（the wheeze），并索要30,000澳元，威胁说如果不给钱就杀了这个孩子。这个电话很快被证实是一个恶作剧。来电者被识别为附近米切尔公园（Mitchell Park）郊区的一名19岁无业青年，他被指控犯有以恐吓手段索取钱财罪。第二个声称有韦瑟相关信息的电话是
made at 9pm on January 17, four days after the initial hoax call. Strangely, this call was placed to a Hackham West resident who lived on Underbank Grove, just two streets away from the Bell's home on Meadow Way, but the recipient of the call had no relation to the Bell family. The unknown mail caller spoke with a slight European accent and claimed he had the wheeze bell in his custody. He sounded noticeably upset, pausing to take deep breaths as he explained that the wheeze was in need of medical assistance, alluding that her injuries were the result of sexual assault. He said the wheeze was happy with him and did not want to go home, but insisted it was a matter of life or death, describing her medical condition as a desperate situation.
在1月17日晚上9点打来的，距离最初的恶作剧电话已经过去四天。奇怪的是，这个电话打给了一位住在Underbank Grove的哈克姆韦斯特居民，这里距离贝尔家所在的Meadow Way只有两条街，但接听电话的人与贝尔一家没有任何关系。这位未知的男性来电者带有轻微的欧洲口音，声称他将韦瑟·贝尔控制在自己手上。他的声音听起来明显很心烦意乱，停顿下来深呼吸，解释说韦瑟需要医疗救助，暗示她的伤势是性侵的结果。他说韦瑟和他在一起很开心，不想回家，但坚持这关乎生死存亡，并将她的医疗状况描述为一种绝望的处境。
The caller explained that he had chosen a phone number at random and was unwilling to contact emergency services for help in case that phone call was traceable. To prove that he was telling the truth, he advised a pair of Louisa's earrings could be found underneath a brick on the corner of South Road and Beach Road in Hackham West, a main intersection just one kilometer from the Bell's property on Meadow Way. Police were immediately informed of the call and rushed to the location specified by the anonymous caller. Sure enough, on the corner of the South Road and Beach Road intersection, they found a broken brick with a pair of small silver hoop earrings hidden underneath. Colin and Diane Bell confirmed the earrings belonged to Louise as they featured a repair her
来电者解释说，他是随机选择的一个电话号码，不愿意联系紧急服务部门寻求帮助，以防这个电话被追踪到。为了证明他说的是实话，他建议可以在哈克姆韦斯特南路（South Road）和海滩路（Beach Road）交汇处拐角处的一块砖头下面找到一副露易丝的耳环，这是一个距离贝尔家所在的Meadow Way仅一公里的主要十字路口。警方立即获悉了这通电话，并冲向匿名来电者指定的地点。果不其然，在南路和海滩路十字路口的拐角处，他们发现了一块碎砖，下面藏着一副银色小圆环耳环。科林和黛安·贝尔确认这对耳环属于露易丝，因为它们的特征是她的
grandfather had made to the catch on one of the items. Certain Louise was wearing the earrings on the night of her disappearance, there was now no doubt she had met with foul play and was in grave danger. In a subsequent press conference, investigators said it was unclear whether the person involved was known to the Bell family, but given the information received during the anonymous phone call, they remained confident that Louise was still alive and was being held captive in the Adelaide area. Attempts to trace the phone call from the perpetrator were unsuccessful. The recipient of the mysterious call had scribbled down as many notes during the conversation as she could, but nothing listed led to the identification of a suspect. However, investigators now had
祖父曾对其中一只耳环的搭扣进行过修理。既然确信露易丝在失踪当晚戴着这对耳环，现在就毫无疑问她遭遇了不测并处于极度危险之中。在随后的新闻发布会上，调查人员表示，目前尚不清楚涉案人员是否为贝尔一家所熟知，但鉴于匿名电话中收到的信息，他们仍然确信露易丝还活着，并被关押在阿德莱德地区。追踪行凶者电话的尝试没有成功。神秘电话的接听者在谈话过程中尽可能多地记下了笔记，但列出的任何内容都没有导致嫌疑人的身份被确认。不过，调查人员现在有了
some information to go by. The suspect had a European accent and it was described as pleasant sounding and well-spoken, with a very good command of English. Days later, on January 20, police received a report from a member of the public who was prompted to call authorities after spotting a man acting suspiciously in the Deep Creek area, 85 kilometers south of Adelaide. The man was in the company of a young girl and the pair were seen with a blue car. Police rushed to the area, but failed to uncover any sign of Louise or her captor. Six weeks went by with no further contact from the alleged perpetrator. Then, on February 28, the underbank Grove resident who had received the phone call that led authorities to the
一些线索可供追踪。嫌疑人带有欧洲口音，被描述为听起来很愉快、谈吐文雅，英语非常流利。几天后的1月20日，警方接到了一位公众的报告，该公众在阿德莱德以南85公里的深溪（Deep Creek）地区发现一名男子行为可疑后，促使他报警。这名男子与一个年轻女孩在一起，两人被看到开着一辆蓝色汽车。警方冲向该地区，但未能发现露易丝或其绑架者的任何踪迹。六个星期过去了，嫌疑人再也没有进一步的联系。接着，在2月28日，那位曾接到电话并引导当局发现露易丝耳环的Underbank Grove居民再次不由自主地卷入了调查。
discovery of Louise's earrings was once again involuntarily involved with the investigation. The woman awoke at 6.45 am and went to collect the milk and newspaper from her front yard when she noticed what appeared to be an old rag laying on her lawn. She paid the item no attention and carried on with her morning routine. Hours later, at around 9 am, she returned home after dropping her son off at school when the rag caught her sight once more as she noticed that was neatly folded. She picked it up and realized it wasn't a rag at all, but a sleeveless cotton pajama top dotted with yellow flowers. It had multiple tears down each side and was drenched in water.
这位女性早上6点45分醒来，走到前院去取牛奶和报纸，这时她注意到草坪上似乎躺着一块旧抹布。她没有理会这件物品，继续着她的晨间日常。几个小时后，大约上午9点，她把儿子送到学校后回到家里，当她注意到那块抹布被折叠得很整齐时，它再次映入她的眼帘。她把它捡起来，意识到这根本不是什么抹布，而是一件点缀着黄色花朵的无袖棉质睡衣上衣。它的两侧有多个撕裂处，并且被水浸透了。
Thinking nothing of it, the woman placed the item of clothing inside an empty pop plant container with the intention of later throwing it away. Half an hour later, she was hit with a stark realization. Louise Bell had been wearing a floral yellow pajama top on the night she went missing. Police were notified of the discovery and presented the item to Colin and Diane Bell. The couple noticed the label from the inside collar of the top was missing, confirming that it belonged to their daughter. Diane herself recalled previously cutting the large red label from the garment after Louise had complained it was itching her neck.
这位女性没有多想，把这件衣服放进了一个空的盆栽容器里，打算稍后把它扔掉。半小时后，她猛然清醒过来。露易丝·贝尔在失踪当晚穿的就是一件黄色碎花睡衣上衣。警方接到这一发现的通知，并将这件物品展示给科林和黛安·贝尔。这对夫妇注意到上衣内领处的标签不见了，这证实了它属于他们的女儿。黛安自己回忆说，以前曾把这件衣服上大大的红色标签剪掉，因为露易丝抱怨它扎脖子。
Having now identified Louise's earrings and pajama top, police were no closer to finding the child or her abductor. At the suggestion of police, the woman who found to Louise's pajama top agreed to be hypnotized in a bid to revive any memories that could assist with the investigation. Under hypnosis, she recalled that when she first left her house to collect the milk and paper at 6.45 am, she noticed the head and shoulders of a clean shaven man with collar length blonde hair hiding behind a brick wall, less than 100 meters from her home. After returning home from dropping her son off at school, the woman also recalled she had seen
现在虽然找到了露易丝的耳环和睡衣上衣，但警方离找到这个孩子或她的绑架者并没有更近一步。在警方的建议下，找到露易丝睡衣上衣的那位女性同意接受催眠，以期唤醒任何能够协助调查的记忆。在催眠状态下，她回忆起自己第一次离开家去取牛奶和报纸（早上6点45分）时，她注意到一个刮得干干净净、留着及领金发、面容干净的男子的头部和肩膀正躲在一堵砖墙后面，距离她的家不到100米。送完儿子上学回家后，这位女性还回忆说，她曾看到
the leg of a man in a nearby walkway. This information led to the theory that the perpetrator had been hiding close by so he could watch as the woman discovered the pajama top. Authorities were convinced the perpetrator was taunting them by distributing Louise's belongings throughout Hackham West with the intention of them being found. It appeared he derived pleasure from this twisted game of cat and mouse. Examination of Louise's pajama shirt revealed it had been removed from her body in such a way that suggested her hands had been bound together at the time. In addition, traces of algae and soil on the waterlogged pajama top were found to contain
附近一条人行道上有一个男人的腿。这些信息引出了一种理论：行凶者一直躲在附近，以便在女性发现睡衣上衣时在一旁观看。当局确信，行凶者通过在哈克姆韦斯特各处散落露易丝的随身物品并意图让他们找到，是在戏弄他们。他似乎从这场扭曲的猫捉老鼠的游戏中获得了快感。对露易丝睡衣衬衫的检查表明，它是在暗示当时她的双手被绑在一起的情况下从她身上脱下来的。此外，浸水睡衣上衣上的藻类和土壤痕迹被发现含有
a unique blend of microbiology found exclusively in the Oncomperinga River, an 88 kilometer long waterway that stretches southwestern from the Mount Lofty Ranges and ends in Port Norlonga, located just eight kilometers from the Bell's family home in Hackham West. An inlet and surrounding riverbanks in Port Norlonga were searched but resulted in no trace of Louise or her abductor. Nevertheless, investigators believed the close proximity between the locations where Louise's earrings and pajama top were found, as well as the source of the algae and soil samples found on the ladder, indicated the perpetrator either lived nearby or had not taken the schoolgirl far. The reward for information regarding
一种独特的微生物群落混合物，这种混合物仅在昂卡帕林加河（Onkaparinga River）中发现。这是一条全长88公里的水道，向西南延伸穿过洛夫蒂山脉（Mount Lofty Ranges），并在距贝尔家族在哈克姆韦斯特的家仅八公里的诺朗加港（Port Norlonga）汇入大海。警方搜查了诺朗加港的一个内河入海口及周边河岸，但没有找到露易丝或其绑架者的任何踪迹。尽管如此，调查人员认为，发现露易丝耳环和睡衣上衣的地点彼此靠得很近，再加上梯子上发现的藻类和土壤样本的来源，这表明行凶者要么住在附近，要么没有把这个女学生带到很远的地方。关于
Louise Bell's whereabouts received a significant boost when a group of anonymous satellite businessmen donated an additional $10,000 for her safe return, raising the total sum of the reward to $15,000. Catholic priest Reverend Father Robert Aiken offered himself as a mediator for the Bell family and made a public plea for the person responsible for Louise's abduction to return the young girl to her family. He invited the perpetrator to make confidential contact with him anytime via phone, at the church, or any other location, reassuring he was just as concerned for the perpetrator's well-being as he was for Louise's. When the priest was asked if offering his services to the potentially dangerous man
露易丝·贝尔下落的悬赏金得到了大幅提升，当时一群匿名的萨特莱特（satellite）商人额外捐赠了10,000澳元以换取她安全归来，使悬赏总额达到了15,000澳元。天主教神父罗伯特·艾肯牧师（Reverend Father Robert Aiken）主动提出担任贝尔一家的调解人，并公开呼吁对露易丝绑架事件负责的人将这个年轻女孩送回她的家人身边。他邀请行凶者随时通过电话、在教堂或任何其他地方与他进行保密联系，并向他保证，他对行凶者福祉的关切绝不亚于对露易丝的关切。当被问及向这个可能危险的男子提供服务是否会
put his own safety at risk, Father Aiken replied, I have no dependence. This girl is just beginning life and I don't mind putting myself in danger if it's going to help someone. Father Aiken's invitation yielded no response. Meanwhile, police continued with their investigation, door knocking over 2,500 homes and conducting interviews with over 8,000 people. Despite these efforts, months passed with no compelling leads or discoveries. Then, crucial information was offered from an unexpected source, when several inmates at the now defunct Adelaide Jail alleged they knew who was responsible
让自己的人身安全处于危险之中时，艾肯神父回答说：“我没有任何依赖。这个女孩才刚刚开始生活，如果这能帮助到某人，我不介意让自己处于危险之中。”艾肯神父的邀请没有得到任何回应。与此同时，警方继续他们的调查，对2500多户家庭进行了走访，并对8000多名人员进行了面谈。尽管做出了这些努力，几个月过去了，依然没有出现令人信服的线索或发现。然后，关键信息从一个意想不到的来源传来，当时现已关闭的阿德莱德监狱（Adelaide Jail）的几名囚犯声称他们知道谁是
for Louise Bell's disappearance. According to four prisoners, in April of 1983, a fellow inmate serving time for an eight-month prison sentence for a string of child sex crimes confessed to murdering Louise. The inmate was 36-year-old father of four, Raymond John Gheesing. Gheesing was not unknown to investigators. He had been interviewed just days after the incident, as he was a known sex offender, who up until just before Louise's disappearance had lived only 500 meters away from her residence in Hackham West. At the time Louise went missing, Gheesing had only just relocated to the Outer City suburb of Torrensville, 29 kilometers away. A link between the suspect and Louise Bell was established via information provided by one of
露易丝·贝尔失踪案的幕后黑手。据四名囚犯称，1983年4月，一名因一系列儿童性犯罪而正在服8个月刑期的同狱犯人承认他谋杀并供认了露易丝的死。这名囚犯是36岁、育有四个孩子的父亲雷蒙德·约翰·吉辛（Raymond John Gheesing）。吉辛对调查人员来说并不陌生。在案发几天后他就被盘问过，因为他是一名知名的性犯罪者，直到露易丝失踪前不久，他一直住在哈克姆韦斯特，距离她家只有500米远。在露易丝失踪时，吉辛才刚刚搬到29公里外的外城郊区托伦斯维尔（Torrensville）。嫌疑人与露易丝·贝尔之间的联系是通过吉辛的
Gheesing's ex-wives. Prior to his move across town to Torrensville, Gheesing served as president of the Hackham West Community Group and had given the Bell family an application form for membership. When cleaning out Gheesing's belongings after their separation, his ex-wife found a piece of paper with Colin Bell's name and address written on it, passed on by another member of the community group to whom the Bells had expressed an interest in joining. Further investigation revealed the Onkaparinga River was a favorite fishing spot of Gheesing's, and a pair of sneakers found in the back of his vehicle contained the same microbiological substance as that found on Louise's pajama top. Based on Raymond John Gheesing's alleged jailhouse confessions, previous residency
其中一位前妻提供的信息建立的。在搬到城另一边的托伦斯维尔之前，吉辛曾担任哈克姆韦斯特社区小组的主席，并曾给贝尔一家发过一份入会申请表。在分居后清理吉辛的物品时，他的前妻发现了一张纸，上面写着科林·贝尔的名字和地址，这是贝尔一家曾向其表达过加入意向的另一位社区小组成员转交的。进一步调查显示，昂卡帕林加河是吉辛最喜欢的钓鱼地点，他车后备箱里的一双运动鞋里含有与露易丝睡衣上衣上相同的微生物物质。根据雷蒙德·约翰·吉辛据称在狱中的供词、此前在
within the Hackham West area, known association with the Bell family, convictions for child sex offenses and the forensic evidence that put him in the vicinity of the Onkaparinga River, police charged him with the abduction and murder of Louise Bell. In November 1984, Gheesing's good trial in the South Australian Supreme Court were only two of the inmate's statements regarding his alleged confession were considered admissible. The prosecution used these as the backbone for their case, and argued that multiple sources claimed Gheesing had showed a consciousness of guilt regarding Louise's disappearance. Although he didn't have a European accent, his well-spoken manner matched the voice described
哈克姆韦斯特地区的居住史、与贝尔一家的已知交往史、儿童性犯罪的前科以及将他置于昂卡帕林加河附近的法医证据，警方指控他绑架并谋杀露易丝·贝尔。1984年11月，吉辛在南澳大利亚州最高法院接受审判，其中关于他所谓供词的囚犯陈述只有两项被认为具有法律效力。控方以此作为他们案件的支柱，并辩称多方信源表明吉辛对露易丝的失踪表现出了负罪感。尽管他没有欧洲口音，但他谈吐文雅的风格与接到电话引导调查人员找到露易丝耳环的哈克姆韦斯特居民所描述的声音相吻合。
by the Hackham West resident who received the phone call that led investigators to Louise's earrings. The only physical evidence linking Gheesing to Louise's disappearance was the microbiological substance found on his sneakers that was also found on Louise's pajama top. Nevertheless, the circumstantial evidence against him was strong, and after 24 hours of deliberation, the jury delivered their verdict. Guilty. Raymond John Gheesing was sentenced to life in prison for the murder of Louise Bell. Gheesing continued to maintain his innocence over Louise's murder, and 17 months into his life sentence, he appealed his conviction. During the appeal hearing, one of the two inmates who had testified against him at trial
将吉辛与露易丝失踪联系起来的唯一物证是他的运动鞋上发现的微生物物质，这种物质也在露易丝的睡衣上衣上被发现。然而，针对他的间接证据非常有力，在经过24小时的审议后，陪审团作出了裁决：有罪。雷蒙德·约翰·吉辛因谋杀露易丝·贝尔被判处终身监禁。吉辛在因谋杀露易丝一事上坚称自己无罪，并在其无期徒刑服刑17个月后对定罪提出了上诉。在上诉听证会上，在审判期间曾对他进行过不利证词指控的两名囚犯之一
retracted their testimony, admitting Gheesing had never confessed to the crime. In another blow to the original trial, the appellate judge determined the statements given by the second inmate who claimed Gheesing had confessed were a complete fabrication. Both witnesses were deemed to be unreliable and untrustworthy, rendering their evidence inadmissible. Without these jailhouse confessions, which formed the entire backbone of the prosecution's case, the highly circumstantial case against Gheesing weakened dramatically. Chief Justice King, who was overseeing the appeal, said, quote, If the evidence is disallowed, the inevitable consequence is that the trial is miscarried,
撤回了他们的证词，承认吉辛从未供认过该罪行。这对原审来说是又一次打击，上诉法官裁定第二名声称吉辛招供的囚犯所提供的陈述纯属捏造。两名证人均被认为不可靠、不值得信任，导致他们的证据无法被采信。如果没有这些构成了控方案件全部支柱的狱中供词，针对吉辛的高度间接证据案情急剧减弱。监督上诉的首席大法官金（Chief Justice King）表示：“引述原话，如果证据不被采纳，不可避免的后果是审判流产，
and the verdict must be set aside. On April 12, 1985, Raymond John Gheesing's conviction for the murder of Louise Bell was quashed by the South Australian Court of Appeal, and he was cleared of all charges relating to her disappearance. Minutes after the hearing came to an end, Gheesing was released from custody, his wrongful conviction referenced as a miscarriage of justice in the Australian legal system. Yet, his release served as an opportunity for Gheesing to continue to harm others. As years later, he was found guilty and sentenced to seven years' prison for child sex crimes committed against two sisters over an eight-year period.
定罪必须被撤销。”1985年4月12日，雷蒙德·约翰·吉辛谋杀露易丝·贝尔的定罪被南澳大利亚州上诉法院撤销，他被洗脱了与她失踪有关的所有罪名。听证会结束几分钟后，吉辛就被释放出狱，他的冤案被提及为澳大利亚法律系统中的一起司法不公。然而，他的获释为吉辛继续伤害他人提供了机会。多年后，他被判定因对两名姐妹在八年期间实施的儿童性犯罪罪名成立，被判处七年监禁。
With Gheesing eliminated as a suspect in the Louise Bell investigation, her case was reopened and her disappearance was once again marked unsolved. In December 1985, almost three years after Louise Bell went missing, a coronial inquest was conducted to examine the cause and circumstances leading to her disappearance. During the inquiry, police confirmed they were no longer actively looking for a suspect, but were instead focusing their investigations on finding the schoolgirl's body in order to provide closure for her family. Although detectives had no suspects, they described the likely perpetrator to be a tall, strong man who was very psychologically abnormal.
随着吉辛被排除在露易丝·贝尔调查案的嫌疑人之外，她的案件重新开立，其失踪案再次被标记为未解悬案。1985年12月，在露易丝·贝尔失踪近三年后，当局进行了验尸研讯，以调查导致她失踪的原因和情况。在调查期间，警方证实他们不再积极寻找嫌疑人，而是将调查重点放在寻找这名女学生的尸体上，以便为她的家属提供一个了结。尽管侦探们没有嫌疑人，但他们将可能的行凶者描述为一名身材高大、强壮且心理极度不正常的男子。
Following the two-day inquest, state coroner Kevin Ahern handed down his findings, concluding that Louise had been abducted from her bedroom during the night of January 4, 1983, in what was likely a sexually motivated attack. He also suggested the perpetrator could be an exhibitionist, given his premeditated actions in exposing certain clues to authorities, such as Louise's pyjama top and earrings. Coroner Ahern said that there was nothing to suggest Louise's disappearance was connected with any other missing children's cases in South Australia, and he found it, quote, very disturbing to realise there are people in the community of
在为期两天的听证会结束后，州验尸官凯文·阿恩（Kevin Ahern）发布了调查结果，得出结论：露易丝于1983年1月4日夜间从她的卧室被绑架，这很可能是一起出于性动机的袭击。他还暗示，鉴于他向当局故意展示某些线索（如露易丝的睡衣上衣和耳环）的预谋行为，行凶者可能是一个暴露狂。验尸官阿恩表示，没有任何迹象表明露易丝的失踪与南澳大利亚州任何其他儿童失踪案有关，并且他发现，引述原话，意识到社区中存在如此
such abnormal mentality. The coroner added that while Louise's body had not yet been located, his official finding presumed she was no longer alive. Determined to get on with their lives, Colin and Diane Bell had not spoken to the media since the early days of the investigation, and were distraught to discover the inquest into their daughter's disappearance was being conducted so close to Christmas. In a reluctant comment to add a late newspaper, the advertiser, Colin Bell said, I just want to be left alone with my family. What's left of it? It's been a tremendous strain on all of us. Only the offender can know what we've been through, and it's water of the ducks back to him. We just want to get our lives back together.
心理不正常的人是非常令人不安的。验尸官补充说，虽然露易丝的尸体尚未找到，但他的官方裁定推断她已经不在人世。决心继续生活的科林和黛安·贝尔自调查初期以来就没有接受过媒体采访，他们震惊地发现，关于女儿失踪的听证会竟然在圣诞节前夕进行。在对晚报《广告人报》（The Advertiser）做出的一句不情愿的评论中，科林·贝尔说：“我只想和我的家人单独呆在一起。还剩下什么呢？这对我们所有人来说都是巨大的压力。只有罪犯才知道我们经历过什么，而这对他来说就像是耳旁风。我们只想把我们的生活重新拼凑起来。”
After the coronial inquest, four years went by with no new information regarding Louise Bell's disappearance, and the case went cold, until a new line of inquiry eventually came to light. On December 30, 1989, a 13-year-old boy was riding his bike in Port no Longa, when the occupant of a white Volkswagen Combi van tricked him into entering his vehicle. The teenager was then bound, gagged, and blindfolded, before the assailant threw the boy's bicycle into the back of the van. After driving nine kilometers south towards the rugged coastline of Maslund's beach, the assailant wiped his captive's bike down and abandoned it against a gate to create the
验尸官听证会后，四年过去了，没有关于露易丝·贝尔失踪的新信息，案件也陷入了僵局，直到一条新的调查方向最终浮出水面。1989年12月30日，一名13岁的男孩在诺朗加港骑着自行车时，一辆白色大众康比货车（Volkswagen Combi van）的驾驶员诱骗他进入了车内。随后，这名少年被捆绑、堵住嘴并蒙上双眼，行凶者将男孩的自行车扔进了货车后备箱。在向南驱车九公里前往马斯林海滩（Maslin's Beach）崎岖的海岸线后，行凶者擦拭了被绑者的自行车，并将其靠在门上遗弃，以制造
illusion the teen was in the area. When the alarm was raised that the teenager was missing, the discovery of his abandoned bike led police to presume he had drowned, and a land and sea search of Maslund's beach ensued. In reality, the teen was being driven to his abductor's property in Hackham West, where he was held captive overnight and subjected to repeated acts of sexual abuse. At midday the following day, the assailant temporarily left the property, giving the brave captive time and opportunity to free himself from his binds. He ran to a house next door, where he raised the alarm and called police for help. The assailant returned home a short while later, oblivious to the fact his captive had escaped,
该少年就在该地区的假象。当这名少年失踪的警报拉响时，他被遗弃的自行车的发现导致警方推测他已经溺水，随之展开了对马斯林海滩的陆海搜救。实际上，这名少年被带到了他在哈克姆韦斯特的绑架者住所，在那里他被关押了一夜，并遭受了多次性虐待。第二天中午，行凶者暂时离开了住所，这给勇敢的被绑者留出了时间和机会挣脱身上的束缚。他跑到隔壁的一家，拉响警报并打电话向警方求助。不久后行凶者返回家中，却完全没有意识到他的被绑者已经逃脱了，
and police were awaiting his arrival. He was promptly placed under arrest. The man responsible for the teenager's attack was 41-year-old Dieter Fenig, a mild-mannered German-born maths and science high school teacher who was married with two daughters. Upon learning his captive had escaped, Fenig admitted to the brazen attack, but said he had only taken the boy because he felt lonely, telling police, quote, I just wanted someone to hug. Dieter Fenig was held in the Christie's Beach police station, where he placed a phone call to his wife admitting he had been thinking about committing the crime for months. Whilst Fenig was in police custody, law enforcement received a phone call from a
警察已经在等候他的到来。他随即被捕。这名对这名青少年发动袭击的男子是41岁的迪eter·费尼格（Dieter Fenig），一名温和的德裔高中数学和科学老师，已婚并育有两个女儿。在得知被他囚禁的人已经逃脱后，费尼格承认了这起猖獗的袭击，但他称自己抓走这个男孩只是因为感到孤独，他告诉警察：“我只是想找个人抱抱。”迪特尔·费尼格被关押在克里斯蒂海滩警察局，在那里他给妻子打了一个电话，承认他几个月来一直有犯罪的念头。在费尼格被警方拘留期间，执法部门接到了一通来自
woman who believed the school teacher could be responsible for another crime. Eleven months prior to Fenig's arrest, on January 18, 1989, 10-year-old Michael Black left his house in the rural Riverside town of Murray Bridge, located 76 kilometers east of Adelaide. Michael hopped on his bicycle and rode towards Sturt Reserve, a popular Riverside recreation area. Michael was looking forward to an afternoon of fishing, taking with him a fishing rod, canvas bag, and his beloved family dog. Sturt Reserve was one of Michael's favorite fishing and swimming spots, where the lush green lawns and calm waters provided the perfect place to cast the line.
一名妇女的电话，她认为这名学校老师可能还犯下了另一起罪行。在费尼格被捕前十一个月，即1989年1月18日，10岁的迈克尔·黑尔（Michael Black）离开了位于阿德莱德以东76公里的默里桥乡村滨河小镇的家。迈克尔骑上自行车，朝默里河畔一个受欢迎的休闲区斯图尔特保护区（Sturt Reserve）驶去。迈克尔期待着一个钓鱼的下午，他随身带了一根鱼竿、一个帆布包和一只他心爱的家庭宠物狗。斯图尔特保护区是迈克尔最喜欢的钓鱼和游泳地点之一，那里郁郁葱葱的绿草地和平静的水面是抛竿的绝佳去处。
Various witnesses spotted Michael at the reserve throughout the day, with the last known sighting occurring just before 3pm. Later that afternoon, his fishing rod, bike, bag, and thongs were found neatly stacked together further upstream at the much quieter fishing spot of Tierley Reserve. His shirt was found in a willow tree even further upstream, where his dog was spotted barking frantically and running up and down the riverbank. No witnesses had seen Michael at Tierley Reserve, and his parents confirmed it was an area their son did not like to frequent, as he was forbidden from venturing there without parental supervision. Although he was a competent swimmer, an extensive
整天都有各种各样的目击者在保护区看到迈克尔，最后一次已知的目击发生在下午3点前不久。那天下午晚些时候，他的鱼竿、自行车、包和人字拖在更上游、更安静的钓鱼点蒂尔利保护区（Tierley Reserve）被发现整齐地堆放在一起。他的衬衫在一个更上游的垂柳树上被发现，他的狗被发现在河岸上疯狂地吠叫并跑来跑去。没有目击者在蒂尔利保护区看到过迈克尔，他的父母证实这是他们儿子不喜欢经常去的地方，因为他被禁止在没有父母监督的情况下冒险去那里。尽管他是一个熟练的游泳运动员，但警察潜水员对该地区进行了广泛的
underwater search of the area was conducted by police divers, as they believed Michael may have drowned. His body wasn't found, nor did it rise to the surface after three days, as was expected in the case of death caused by drowning. According to officers in charge of the investigation, the possibility that Michael's body lay undiscovered in the water was incredibly slim, and he was officially declared a missing person. While Dieter Fenig was in custody for the abduction and assault committed against the 13-year-old boy taken from Port Nollunga, a witness reported that Fenig had been at her house around the time of Michael Black's disappearance. When a story about the missing boy aired on the news,
水下搜寻，因为他们认为迈克尔可能已经溺水身亡。他的尸体没有被找到，也没有像溺水身亡通常预期那样在三天后浮上水面。据负责调查的警官称，迈克尔的尸体未被发现在水中的可能性极其渺茫，他被正式宣布为失踪人口。当迪特尔·费尼格因绑架和袭击从诺伦加港带走的13岁男孩而被拘留时，一位目击者报告说，在迈克尔·黑尔失踪期间，费尼格曾去过她家。当一篇关于失踪男孩的新闻播出时，
Fenig remarked he had been at Sturt Reserve on the day Michael was last seen, and he had helped the young boy with his fishing rod. Police interviewed Fenig's wife, who confirmed her husband had been away from home during the time of Michael Black's disappearance, leaving for a three-day trip in his convivant to study physics in preparation for an upcoming teaching job. According to Fenig's daughter, her father said he lent Michael a knife to help him scale a fish and asked the young boy to return the knife to his van once he was done. In addition, multiple witnesses confirmed having seen a white combie speeding away from Tierley Reserve on the day Michael vanished. Police identified many
费尼格评论说，在迈克尔最后一次被人看到的当天，他曾在斯图尔特保护区，并且他曾帮这个小男孩弄过鱼竿。警察盘问了费尼格的妻子，她证实丈夫在迈克尔·黑尔失踪期间不在家，他开着大众露营车进行了一次为期三天的旅行去学习物理，为即将到来的教职做准备。据费尼格的女儿说，她父亲说他借给迈克尔一把刀来帮他给鱼刮鳞，并要求小男孩用完后把刀还到他的面包车里。此外，多名目击者证实，在迈克尔失踪当天，曾看到一辆白色大众露营车从蒂尔利保护区超速驶离。警方发现迈克尔
similarities between Michael's unsolved case and Dieter Fenig's recent crimes against the 13-year-old boy. They suspected Fenig made efforts to mislead police by setting up Michael's bicycle to appear as though the child had drowned, just like he had done when committing the following abduction 11 months later. Subsequently, Fenig was charged with the murder of Michael Black. Given the location of his home in Hackham West, he also became a person of interest in another high-profile unsolved case, the disappearance of Louise Bell. There were multiple factors pinpointing Dieter Fenig as a suspect for Louise's abduction. Firstly, the 10-year-old had attended school and played on the same basketball team as one of Fenig's daughters, and the two were familiar
未解悬案与迪特尔·费尼格最近对13岁男孩犯罪的行为之间存在许多相似之处。他们怀疑费尼格试图通过摆放迈克尔的自行车来误导警方，使其看起来像是儿童溺水身亡，就像他在11个月后实施随后的绑架时所做的那样。随后，费尼格被指控谋杀迈克尔·黑尔。鉴于他位于哈克姆韦斯特（Hackham West）的住所的位置，他还成为了另一起备受瞩目的未解悬案——路易丝·贝尔（Louise Bell）失踪案的嫌疑人。有多种因素将迪特尔·黑尔（应为Fenig）锁定为路易丝绑架案的嫌疑人。首先，这个10岁的女孩曾与费尼格的一个女儿上过同一所学校并参加过同一个篮球队，两人互相熟悉。
with one another. Fenig was also known to frequent the Onkaparinga River in his canoe, a key location of interest in Louise's abduction due to the algae and soil samples found on her pajamas. Additionally, Fenig was an insomniac known by family members and neighbors to walk the streets late at night. He lived on Holly Rise, a street just seven minutes walk away from the Bell property on Meadow Way, with the two homes connected by a series of quiet laneways that would have provided ample opportunity for him to transport the young girl without being seen. However, Fenig provided police with an alibi for the night of Louise's disappearance. He had been on holiday with his family visiting relatives in Swan Hill, a riverside town in
众所周知，费尼格经常划独木舟去翁卡帕林加河（Onkaparinga River），这是路易丝绑架案中一个关键的利益地点，因为在她的睡衣上发现了藻类和土壤样本。此外，据家人和邻居所知，费尼格患有失眠症，经常在深夜街头行走。他住在霍利莱斯（Holly Rise），这条街距离贝尔家所在的米多韦（Meadow Way）仅七分钟步行路程，两栋房子通过一系列安静的小巷相连，这为他在不被发现的情况下运送小女孩提供了充足的机会。然而，费尼格向警方提供了一个关于路易丝失踪当晚的不在场证明。他和家人在度假，拜访位于维多利亚州邻州的滨河小镇天鹅山（Swan Hill）的亲戚。他的妻子和女儿一直住在一个大篷车里，而费尼格则独自住在另一个出租的大篷车里。
the neighboring state of Victoria. His wife and daughters had been staying in one caravan while Fenig had been staying in a separate rental caravan on his own. Investigators tracked down the caravan rental company and discovered Dieter Fenig had actually returned his caravan on January 4, putting him back in Adelaide during the night of Louise's abduction while his family remained in Swan Hill. This was confirmed by a former neighbor who had been instructed to water the Fenig's garden while the family was in Victoria. In the days following Louise's disappearance, the neighbor noticed that Dieter Fenig had returned home early, so we went over to notify him about the events of the previous few days. When Fenig opened the door, he was
调查人员追踪了房车租赁公司，发现迪特尔·费尼格实际上在1月4日就归还了房车，这使他在路易丝被绑架当晚回到了阿德莱德，而他的家人则留在了天鹅山。这一点得到了一名前邻居的证实，该邻居曾受托在费尼格一家在维多利亚州期间帮他们浇花。在路易丝失踪后的几天里，这位邻居注意到迪特尔·费尼格已经提前回家了，于是他过去通知他前几天发生的事情。当费尼格打开门时，他
noticeably dishevelled and was alleged to have remarked, there goes my alibi. In February 1991, a thorough search for the remains of Michael Black and to Louise Bell was conducted at Fenig's property on Holly Rise. Floorboards in two bedrooms were pulled up and a section of the backyard and a rear shed were excavated, but no human remains, physical evidence, or anything else of interest was uncovered. For the kidnapping and sexual assault committed against the 13-year-old boy from Port Nollonga, Dieter Fenig pleaded guilty, but professed his innocence for any other crimes. With the strong circumstantial evidence against him, he stood trial for the murder of Michael Black, entering a plea of not guilty. In a highly controversial move,
明显衣冠不整，据称还评论说：“我的不在场证明这下完了。”1991年2月，警方对费尼格在霍利莱斯的房产进行了彻底搜查，寻找迈克尔·黑尔和路易丝·贝尔的遗骸。两间卧室的地板被掀开，后院的一部分和后院的棚屋被挖掘，但没有发现人类遗骸、物证或其他任何有趣的东西。对于对诺伦加港13岁男孩实施的绑架和性侵犯，迪特尔·费尼格表示认罪，但坚称自己对其他罪行是无辜的。在对他不利的强力间接证据面前，他因谋杀迈克尔·黑尔而受审，并做出了无罪抗辩。在一项极具争议的举动中，
the judge allowed propensity evidence, otherwise known as similar fact evidence, to be presented at trial. This meant Fenig's other related convictions were permitted to be referenced during his current trial and used as evidence against him. Permitting similar fact evidence is rarely allowed due to concerns the defendant may be unfairly judged, but the presiding judge for the Michael Black murder trial felt it essential that jury be made aware of Fenig's prior criminal history involving children. Based on circumstantial evidence and statements from over 100 witnesses, Dieter Fenig was convicted of Michael Black's murder and sentenced to 38 years in prison. He remained a person of interest in Louise Bell's disappearance, but police had no concrete evidence to link him
法官允许在审判中出示倾向性证据，也就是所谓的相似事实证据。这意味着在当前的审判中，可以提及费尼格的其他相关定罪，并将其作为对他的不利证据。允许相似事实证据的情况很少见，因为人们担心被告可能会受到不公正的审判，但审理迈克尔·黑尔谋杀案审判的主审法官认为，让陪审团了解费尼格先前涉及儿童的犯罪历史是至关重要的。根据间接证据和来自100多名证人的陈词，迪特尔·费尼格被判谋杀迈克尔·黑尔罪名成立，被判处38年监禁。他仍然是路易丝·贝尔失踪案的嫌疑人，但警方没有确凿的证据将他
to the crime and the case eventually went cold. During the earlier years of the Louise Bell investigation, the suspect pool included convicted killer couple Valmay Beck and Barry Watts. The couples known crimes are covered in case 101 of case file, but investigators nationwide believed Beck and Watts might have been responsible for the unsolved disappearance of a number of young women in Australia throughout the 1980s. Prior to her death in 2008, Valmay Beck was interrogated at length about Louise Bell, but she failed to reveal any information that solidified her or Barry Watts were involved in the crime. Passing away without the deathbed confession, many had hoped for. By mid-2009, 26 years had passed since Louise vanished in the middle of
与该罪行联系起来，该案最终成了悬案。在路易丝·贝尔调查的早期，嫌疑人池中包括被定罪的杀手夫妇瓦尔迈·贝克（Valmay Beck）和巴里·沃茨（Barry Watts）。这对夫妇已知的罪行在档案案例101中有涉及，但全国各地的调查人员认为，贝克和沃茨可能应对20世纪80年代澳大利亚多起年轻女性未解失踪案负责。在2008年去世之前，瓦尔迈·贝克曾就路易丝·贝尔一案接受了长时间的审讯，但她未能透露任何能够证实她或巴里·沃茨参与该罪行的信息。她带着许多人所期望的、临终前的坦白遗憾离世。到2009年中期，自从路易丝在半夜从自己的卧室失踪以来已经过去了26年，她的悬案重新开启，希望法证技术的进步能为调查带来新的机遇。
the night from her own bedroom and her cold case was reopened with the hopes that advances in forensic technology could lead to new opportunities in the investigation. A team of investigators were assigned to undertake a comprehensive review of the case and re-examine all available evidence. Efforts proved fruitful, with forensic experts identifying and extracting several previously undiscovered traces of DNA evidence on the pajama top Louise had been wearing on the night of her abduction. The technology wasn't quite advanced enough to link the DNA to a suspect, but in 2012, Louise's pajama top was sent to a leading forensic institution in the Netherlands, allowing for a new DNA testing technique known as the low-copy method to be used.
一组调查人员被指派对该案进行全面审查，并重新审查所有可用证据。事实证明，这些努力取得了成果，法证专家在路易丝在被绑架当晚穿的睡衣上识别并提取了几处以前未被发现的DNA证据痕迹。这项技术还不足以将DNA与嫌疑人联系起来，但在2012年，路易丝的睡衣上衣被送到荷兰的一家领先法证机构，从而可以使用一种名为低拷贝法的新DNA检测技术。
This was a significantly more advanced technique than the testing method available in Australia at the time, allowing for a DNA profile to be extracted from sweat or just a few skin cells. The testing of the unidentified DNA found on Louise's pajama top resulted in a match. It belonged to a prisoner currently serving time in the Port Lincoln prison on the air peninsula of South Australia at a likelihood ratio of higher than a billion to one. The prisoner was not unknown to the investigation. He had been considered a strong person of interest in Louise's disappearance since 1989, but failure to uncover concrete evidence at the time withheld an arrest. The DNA on Louise's clothing belonged to Hackham West Local and convicted child killer,
这比当时澳大利亚可用的检测技术先进得多，允许从汗液或仅仅几个皮肤细胞中提取DNA图谱。对在路易丝的睡衣上发现的未识别DNA的检测结果显示匹配。它属于目前正在南澳大利亚州艾尔半岛林肯港监狱服刑的一名囚犯，似然比超过十亿分之一。这名囚犯对调查人员来说并不陌生。自1989年以来，他一直被认为是路易丝失踪案的重要嫌疑人，但当时未能发现确凿证据导致未能实施逮捕。路易丝衣服上的DNA属于哈克姆韦斯特当地人、被定罪的儿童杀手
Dieter Fenig. Back in 1991, Fenig's former Hackham West property was searched for clues regarding the Louise Bell investigation, but efforts resulted in no worthwhile discoveries. Twenty-one years later, in 2012, police returned to the address, prepared to conduct a more extensive excavation of the yard in the hopes of finally uncovering Louise's remains. With assistance from the Australian Federal Police, state-of-the-art radar equipment was used to detect abnormalities underground, with special attention paid to three distinct concrete slabs at the rear of the property. Concrete cutters were used to remove the slabs, with police then using sifting pans, hand trails and shovels to dig around and examine the soil underneath.
迪特尔·费尼格。早在1991年，警方就搜查了费尼格前哈克姆韦斯特房产，寻找有关路易丝·贝尔调查的线索，但努力没有带来任何有价值的发现。二十一年后的2012年，警察重返该地址，准备对院子进行更广泛的挖掘，希望能最终找到路易丝的遗骸。在澳大利亚联邦警察的协助下，使用了最先进的雷达设备来探测地下的异常情况，并特别关注了房产后部的三个不同的混凝土板。使用混凝土切割机移除了石板，然后警察使用筛盘、手铲和铁锹在周围挖掘并检查底部的土壤。
Four days of extensive searching ensued, overseen by a heavy media presence, as the community anticipated answers to the decade's long mystery as to what happened to Louise Bell. Small fragments of bone were found, but were later determined to have belonged to animals. Overall, the dig uncovered nothing of significance. Police continued with their inquiries, following up on over 550 statements taken from family members, witnesses and other members of the public throughout the original investigation. In similar circumstances to the wrongful conviction of Raymond John Geasing, two separate inmates who had served time with Dieter Fennig during his 38-year sentence for
随后进行了为期四天的广泛搜寻，在庞大的媒体关注下进行，因为公众期待着长达数十年的关于路易丝·贝尔遭遇了什么谜团的答案。发现了小块骨头，但后来确定属于动物。总的来说，挖掘没有发现任何重要意义的东西。警方继续进行他们的调查，跟进了在最初调查期间从家庭成员、目击者和公众其他成员那里采集的550多份证词。在与雷蒙德·约翰·吉辛（Raymond John Geasing）冤案类似的情况下，两名曾在迪特尔·费尼格因谋杀迈克尔·黑尔而被判38年监禁期间与他一起服刑的狱友挺身而出，
the murder of Michael Black came forward, declaring that the former teacher had confessed to Louise's murder. Fennig was allegedly drinking bootleg alcohol and smoking cannabis with a fellow inmate during an in-house Christmas celebration when he started sobbing and confessed for killing Michael Black. He said he couldn't tell authorities where Michael's body was located because, quote, there is a chick there. When the prisoner asked what chick, Fennig replied, Bell. He allegedly admitted that he took the young girl and killed her by accident, leaving the pajama top on the front lawn of the underbank Grove resident because he felt guilty for what he had done. Using a prison computer, Fennig brought up a map of Hackham West and
宣称这位前老师供认了谋杀路易丝。据称，费尼格在狱中举行圣诞庆祝活动时，正与一名狱友喝着私酿酒并抽着大麻，这时他开始抽泣并供认了谋杀迈克尔·黑尔。他说他不能告诉当局迈克尔的尸体在哪里，因为：“那里有个小妞。”当狱友问是什么小妞时，费尼格回答：“贝尔。”据称他承认自己带走了那个小女孩并不小心杀害了她，把睡衣上衣留在了班克格罗夫（underbank Grove）居民的前草坪上，因为他为自己所做的事感到内疚。费尼格用监狱的电脑调出了哈克姆韦斯特的地图，
showed the inmate how close the distance was between his former home and the Bell property. He claimed that Louise exited her house via the bedroom window and went with him willingly. A ordained Baptist minister serving time for fraud also alleged Fennig had confessed to Louise's murder while seeking his spiritual guidance. The minister claimed Fennig's whole body shook when he started talking about the crime, saying he hated the name Bell because it reminded him, quote, of something that's eating at my heart every day. Fennig allegedly told the minister he wasn't concerned about the crimes he was in jail for, but rather for the things that hadn't yet come to light, claiming he knew everything about Louise
并向狱友展示了他以前的家和贝尔家之间的距离有多近。他声称路易丝通过卧室窗户离开了家，并自愿和他一起走了。一名因欺诈罪服刑的按立浸信会牧师也声称，费尼格在寻求他的精神指导时供认了谋杀路易丝。这位牧师声称，当费尼格开始谈论这起犯罪时，他的全身都在发抖，并说他讨厌“贝尔”这个名字，因为它提醒他：“每天都在啃食我内心的东西。”据称，费尼格告诉牧师，他并不关心自己因何入罪，而是关心那些尚未大白于天下的事情，并声称他知道关于路易丝·贝尔的一切，
Bell, including the location of her body. He said he had picked her up, carried her away, and only decided to kill her when she wouldn't calm down or cooperate. The minister encouraged Fennig to confess to police, but he refused, saying, I know I'm not going to make it out of prison, why should I bother? He later showed the same inmate and manuscript he had been writing, which told the story of a warrior attempting to rescue a young girl. The girl refused to believe the warrior genuinely wanted to help her, and for her lack of trust, she ends up dying. Police were able to recover copies of the manuscript from Fennig's cell. On November 18, 2013, 65-year-old Dita Fennig was arrested for the murder of Louise Bell.
包括她尸体的位置。他说他把她抱起来带走，只有在她不肯安静下来或不合作时才决定杀死她。牧师鼓励费尼格向警方坦白，但他拒绝了，并说道：“我知道我活着出不去监狱了，我为什么还要费劲？”他后来向同一个狱友展示了他一直在写的手稿，其中讲述了一个战士试图拯救一个年轻女孩的故事。女孩拒绝相信战士是真心想帮她，由于她的不信任，她最终死去了。警方设法从费尼格的牢房里找回了手稿的副本。2013年11月18日，65岁的迪特尔·费尼格因谋杀路易丝·贝尔被捕。
Deputy Police Commissioner Grant Stevens addressed the media, quote, clearly this particular matter has had a massive impact on the family. They are devastated by this crime, and the fact that we have conducted this arrest today will in some respects provide a degree of closure. It's good news, but it's tinged with that degree of sadness that the family are now going through another episode of this particularly gruesome story. Given Fennig's prior convictions and known reputation as a child killer, officials were concerned that he may not receive a fair trial. It was argued a jury would find it impossible to overlook his well-known and established depraved character, impacting their verdict
副警察专员格兰特·史蒂文斯（Grant Stevens）向媒体发表讲话：“显然，这件事情对这个家庭产生了巨大的影响。他们被这起罪行摧毁了，我们在今天进行这次逮捕，在某种程度上将提供一定程度的了结。这是个好消息，但它伴随着一定程度的悲伤，因为这个家庭正在经历这个特别可怕的故事的又一集。”鉴于费尼格先前的定罪以及作为儿童杀手的声誉，官员们担心他可能无法获得公正的审判。有人认为陪审团会发现不可能忽视他众所周知且既定的堕落性格，从而影响他们的裁决，
regardless of the evidence presented. The wrongful conviction of Raymond John Geasing for the same crime three decades earlier stemming from false confessions provided by inmates ensured the courts and prosecution were treading extra carefully this time around. To avoid the risk of an unfair trial, it was decided that Fennig would face court in front of a judge alone, with no jury present. Celebrated criminal barrister and Supreme Court Judge Justice Michael David, who was well versed in the intricacies of the case and other trials that resulted in a miscarriage of justice, temporarily came out of retirement to oversee the trial, which commenced in September 2015, two years after Fennig's arrest.
无论出示什么证据。三十年前雷蒙德·约翰·吉辛因狱友提供的虚假供词而对同一罪行蒙受不白之冤，这确保了法院和检方这次格外谨慎。为了避免不公正审判的风险，决定由法官一人审理费尼格的案件，不设陪审团。著名刑事大律师兼最高法院法官迈克尔·大卫（Michael David）大法官精通该案及其他导致冤假错案的审判的复杂性，他暂时复出监督审判，审判于2015年9月开始，即费尼格被捕两年后。
Prosecutor Sandy McDonald opened her arguments by saying there was no doubt that Louise was no longer alive. Quote, in the early days there was still hope. Over three decades later, Louise Bell is not coming home. Louise Bell is dead. She was murdered. She was taken from her bedroom in the middle of the night in the most brazen and audacious way. McDonald said the biggest mystery in the case was how Louise got out of her bedroom. Given the difficulties of shifting a 30 to 40 kilogram child from their bed without waking her sister in the same room or parents in the adjoining room, McDonald said it was far more likely that Louise was enticed from her room by someone she knew and recognized rather than a stranger.
检察官桑迪·麦克唐纳（Sandy McDonald）开案陈词时表示，毫无疑问路易丝已经不在人世了。“在早期，还有希望。三十多年过去了，路易丝·贝尔没有回家。路易丝·贝尔死了。她被谋杀了。她以最厚颜无耻、最大胆的方式在半夜从她的卧室被带走。”麦克唐纳说，本案最大的谜团是路易丝是如何离开她的卧室的。考虑到把一个30到40公斤重的孩子从床上转移而不惊醒同房的姐姐或隔壁房间的父母有多么困难，麦克唐纳说，路易丝更有可能是被她认识和熟悉的人而不是陌生人从房间里诱骗出去的。
During the trial, witness accounts were heard from the inmates who Fennig allegedly confessed to, as well as former neighbors, colleagues and family members who said the accused had demonstrated an unusual interest in the crime. One former colleague alleged Fennig encouraged him to join in on nightly runs, saying, it's amazing what you can see through windows. During a conversation with another former colleague, Fennig's coworker expressed her disbelief that the schoolgirl had been taken from her bedroom without anybody seeing or hearing a thing. Fennig calmly replied that he believed that was very possible as he often walked the streets at night and never saw another living soul. Yet another colleague claimed Fennig told them he was a suspect in the case,
在审判期间，听取了费尼格据称向其供认的狱友的证词，以及前邻居、同事和家人的证词，他们称被告对这起罪行表现出了不同寻常的兴趣。一位前同事声称，费尼格鼓励他一起参加夜跑，并说：“通过窗户你能看到的东西真是令人惊奇。”在与另一位前同事交谈时，费尼格的同事对这个女学生在没有任何人看到或听到任何动静的情况下从卧室被带走表示难以置信。费尼格平静地回答说，他认为这是非常可能的，因为他经常在晚上走在街上，从未看到过另一个活人。还有一位同事声称费尼格告诉他们自己是该案的嫌疑人，
which prosecuted Sandy McDonald labelled an important piece of evidence. Quote, Why on earth would a father, teacher, a family man be telling his colleague and friend that he was a suspect in the abduction and murder of a little girl when he's not? It makes no sense, unless he's getting some sort of perverse pleasure drawing attention to himself, continuing to talk about it. One of Fennig's daughters who had been a classmate of Louisa's testified against her father, saying he had a habit of changing the subject whenever she questioned him about Louise. Her father always claimed who had been interstate with the family during the critical time period over Louise's abduction when she knew he had returned home
检察官桑迪·麦克唐纳将此称为一条重要证据。“一个父亲、老师、顾家的男人，在自己不是嫌疑人的情况下，为什么会莫名其妙地告诉他的同事和朋友他是绑架和谋杀一个小女孩案的嫌疑人？这毫无意义，除非他在吸引人们注意、继续谈论这件事的过程中获得某种变态的快感。”费尼格的一个女儿曾是路易丝的同班同学，她出庭指证她的父亲，称每当她向他询问有关路易丝的事情时，他都有转移话题的习惯。她的父亲总是声称在路易丝被绑架的关键时期他随家人去了外地，而她知道他很早就独自从假期回家了。
alone from the holiday early. Fennig's ex-wife also gave evidence against him, confirming her former husband had indeed returned to Adelaide early in January 1983, while the family continued on with their interstate holiday without him. When they returned home, Fennig cooked them dinner, which she described as exceptionally unusual. Quote, Dita never made anything, he wouldn't even make me a cup of tea. One of Louise's classmates provided a statement via video link saying she had seen Louise walking home with Fennig and his daughter up to six times in the year leading up to her abduction. Louise's younger sister Rachel testified that she saw Fennig's convivant parked on their street
费尼格的前妻也出庭指证他，证实她的前夫确实在1983年1月早早回到了阿德莱德，而家人则继续在没有他的情况下进行他们的跨州假期。当他们回家时，费尼格给他们做了晚饭，她将其形容为极其反常。“迪特尔从来不做任何东西，他甚至都不会给我泡杯茶。”路易丝的一位同学通过视频连线提供了证词，称在路易丝被绑架前的一年里，她曾多达六次看到路易丝和费尼格以及他的女儿一起走回家。路易丝的妹妹蕾切尔（Rachel）作证说，在她姐姐失踪后的几年里，她看到费尼格的露营车停在他们街上邻居的房子前面。
in front of a neighbour's house in the years following her sister's disappearance. In addition, the underbank Grove resident who had received a phone call from the abductor that led to the discovery of Louise's earrings claimed a German-born Fennig's voice matched the European accent of the unknown caller. A taxi driver also testified that a man with a slightly European accent asked him to take him for a bizarre drive-by of the bell home in the days following the 10-year-old's disappearance. Halfway through the trial, Fennig suffered a heart attack in prison and was rushed to hospital where he underwent surgery and was placed in an induced coma. The future of the trial looked questionable until he made a full recovery and was cleared to
此外，那位接到绑架者电话从而导致路易丝耳环被发现的班克格罗夫居民声称，德裔费尼格的声音与未知来电者的欧洲口音相吻合。一名出租车司机也作证说，在一个10岁女孩失踪后的几天里，一个略带欧洲口音的男子要求他带他去贝尔家进行一次诡异的驱车巡视。审判进行到一半时，费尼格在狱中突发心脏病被紧急送往医院，在那里他接受了手术并陷入人工昏迷。审判的未来看起来成问题，直到他完全康复并在三周后被批准重返法庭。
return to court three weeks later. Although the witness statements and jailhouse confessions provided strong circumstantial evidence, Fennig's DNA on Louise's pajama top provided a compelling piece of physical evidence. Defense lawyer Paul Charman argued that this evidence wasn't foolproof as there had been inconsistencies and contradictions in the results of testing conducted by different labs, techniques and software. Initial testing of DNA found on Louise's pajama shirt in an Adelaide laboratory had revealed a likelihood ratio that the DNA belonged to Dieter Fennig was 6400 to 1, a stark contrast to the billion to one ratio determined by the lab in the Netherlands. Despite the court receiving an in-depth explanation of how the Dutch forensic team
尽管证人证词和狱中供词提供了强有力的间接证据，但费尼格在路易丝睡衣上留下的DNA提供了令人信服的物证。辩护律师保罗·夏曼（Paul Charman）辩称，这一证据并非万无一失，因为不同实验室、技术和软件进行的测试结果存在不一致和矛盾。在阿德莱德实验室对在路易丝的睡衣衬衫上发现的DNA进行的初步测试显示，该DNA属于迪特尔·费尼格的似然比为6400比1，这与荷兰实验室测得的十亿分之一的比率形成鲜明对比。尽管法院听取了关于荷兰法证团队如何实现其低拷贝DNA图谱精确结果的深入解释，但夏曼辩称：
achieved the precise results of their low-copy DNA profiling, Charman argued. While scientists say they can justify the varied results from a scientific point of view, that doesn't mean your honor can accept they proved the DNA case beyond a reasonable doubt. He asked the court to be mindful that Fennig's DNA was not found on Louise's windowsill or anywhere else at the crime scene. The defense team clung to this argument throughout most of the trial before presenting another theory to explain how Fennig's DNA appeared on Louise's pajamas. In November 1982, less than two months before Louise's abduction, she attended a pool party at the home of her basketball coach as part of the team's end of season breakup.
“虽然科学家从科学角度说他们可以证明各种结果的合理性，但这并不意味着法官大人可以接受他们已将DNA案件证明到无可置疑的程度。”他请法庭注意，在路易丝的窗台上或其他犯罪现场没有发现费尼格的DNA。辩护团队在审判的大部分时间里都紧抓这一论点不放，随后提出了另一种理论来解释费尼格的DNA是如何出现在路易丝的睡衣上的。1982年11月，即路易丝被绑架前不到两个月，她参加了她篮球队教练家的一场泳池派对，作为球队赛季结束告别的一部分。
In attendance was another of Louise's teammates, Dieter Fennig's daughter. The defense argued the defendant's DNA could have been passed onto Louise and subsequently onto her pajamas via contact with his daughter during the pool party, school, or basketball games in a process known as secondary transfer. But the prosecution destroyed this theory when it was confirmed that Louise had received the pajama top as a Christmas present a month after the pool party. Louise had had no physical contact with Fennig's daughter since obtaining the clothing. The shirt had also been machine washed prior to the schoolgirl's abduction, which would have removed any DNA passed on via secondary transfer.
出席的还有路易丝的另一位队友，即迪特尔·费尼格的女儿。辩护方辩称，被告的DNA可能是通过在泳池派对、学校或篮球比赛期间与他女儿接触的过程中传给了路易丝，并随后传到了她的睡衣上，这被称为二次转移过程。但当证实路易丝在泳池派对一个月后作为圣诞礼物收到了这件睡衣上衣时，控方彻底粉碎了这一理论。自获得这件衣服以来，路易丝与费尼格的女儿没有任何身体接触。在这名女学生被绑架之前，这件衬衫还被机洗过，这会清除任何通过二次转移传递的DNA。
The defense attempted to discredit the inmates who Fennig had allegedly confessed to, asking one of them if they were lying to receive attention. The inmate, who had been diagnosed by a psychiatrist as having an antisocial personality with a history of manipulative behavior, responded to the accusation in a hostile manner, introducing concerns about his reliability. Yet, the same psychiatrist agreed that this disorder would not impact the inmate's ability to provide a reliable witness statement. The prosecution pointed out that the two confessions were provided entirely separate of one another, with no opportunity for collusion between the two inmates. In addition, both had
辩护方试图抹黑费尼格据称向其供认的狱友，问其中一人是否为了引起注意而说谎。这名被精神科医生诊断为具有反社会人格且有操纵行为历史的狱友以敌对的方式回应了这一指控，引发了对其可信度的担忧。然而，同一位精神科医生同意，这种疾病不会影响该狱友提供可靠证词的能力。控方指出，这两份供词完全独立提供，两个狱友之间没有勾结的机会。此外，两人都在路易丝的睡衣上发现费尼格的DNA之前，就关于供词的信息向警方报案。
gone to police with information about the confessions prior to Fennig's DNA match being found on Louise's pajamas. The unique nature of the judge-only trial allowed for multiple adjournments and various sittings, resulting in a trial that lasted for close to a year, ending in July 2016. Although Justice Michael David could not determine the exact circumstances of how Louise left her home the night she disappeared, he believed a forceful abduction would have almost certainly woken another family member. Therefore, he found it more likely Louise was enticed out the window by someone she was familiar with. 33 years after 10-year-old Louise Bell went missing, Justice David delivered his verdict to the packed courtroom, finding
法官独审的独特性质允许进行多次休庭和各种开庭，导致审判持续了将近一年，于2016年7月结束。尽管迈克尔·大卫大法官无法确定路易丝失踪当晚离开她家的确切情况，但他相信一次强行绑架几乎肯定会惊醒家里的其他成员。因此，他发现路易丝更有可能是被她熟悉的人诱骗出窗外的。在10岁的路易丝·贝尔失踪33年后，大卫大法官在挤满人的法庭上宣读了裁决，裁定迪特尔·费尼格的绑架和谋杀罪名成立。
Dieter Fennig guilty for her abduction and murder. In an unusual move, Justice David implored the accused to lead authorities to the bodies of both children he had been found guilty of killing, Louise Bell and Michael Black, saying his sentencing may or may not be affected by Fennig's cooperation in fulfilling this request. After the verdict was delivered, a media release provided by the Bell family was read outside the court by a detective who had worked on the case. Quote, Today's verdict leaves us feeling relieved, and while it is a significant outcome, it is not the end of this difficult journey. Our beloved 10-year-old daughter was taken from her own bedroom, a place where she should be safe and has never come home. Words cannot describe
在大卫大法官采取的一个不寻常举动中，他恳求被告引导当局找到他被判谋杀的两名儿童——路易丝·贝尔和迈克尔·黑尔的遗骸，并表示他的量刑可能会或可能不会受到费尼格配合完成此请求的影响。宣判后，曾参与该案的一名侦探在法庭外宣读了贝尔家族提供的媒体声明：“今天的裁决让我们感到如释重负，虽然这是一个重大的结果，但这并不是这段艰难旅程的终点。我们心爱的10岁女儿从她自己的卧室被带走，这是一个她本该感到安全的地方，却再也没有回家。言语无法形容这对我们的生活造成的影响。今天是为路易丝寻找答案的斗争的结晶。这就是为什么今天的决定如此重要。这是路易丝的小小胜利。我们想感谢所有人为试图将路易丝带回我们身边以及起诉此案所做的坚持和努力。虽然今天是一个重要的里程碑，但我们想要我们的女儿回来，所以我呼吁任何有线索能协助我们找到路易丝的人现在就站出来。虽然今天下午的结果意义重大，但这只是这起可怕事件的一部分。我们仍然希望能让路易丝入土为安。”
the impact this has had on our lives. Today is the culmination of our struggles to find answers for Louise. That is what makes today's decision so important. It is a small victory for Louise. We would like to thank everyone for their persistence and efforts in trying to return Louise to us and in prosecuting this matter. While today is a significant milestone, we want our daughter back, so I would appeal to anyone with information that might assist us in finding Louise to come forward now. While this afternoon's outcome is significant, it is only part of this terrible event. We still want to be able to lay Louise to rest. The Bell Family made it clear this would be the only statement they would be providing to the
贝尔家族明确表示，这将是他们向公众发表的唯一声明。他们还呼吁在费尼格宣判时将他们的受害人影响陈述从媒体中隐去，因为担心公布他们的感受会造成不必要的痛苦。为了安抚他们的请求，法院同意贝尔家族不必提供受害人影响陈述。此后他们再也没有公开谈论过这个案子。南澳大利亚警方证实，尽管有罪判决已下，但在找回路易丝的遗骸之前，此案不会结案。侦探总督察德斯·布雷（Desbray）表示：“我呼吁任何有线索能协助我们找到她的人，摸摸你们的良心，现在就站出来。是时候做正确的事了。”
public. They also appealed for their victim impact statements to be suppressed from the media at Phoenix Sentencing amidst concerns the publication of their feelings would cause unnecessary hardship. To appease their request, the court agreed the Bell Family did not have to provide victim impact statements. They have not spoken publicly about the case since. South Australian police confirmed that despite the guilty verdict, the case would not be closed until Louise's remains were recovered. Detective Superintendent Desbray quote, I would appeal for anyone with information that might assist us to find her, to search your conscience and to come forward now. It is time to do the right thing.
到2016年12月6日宣判之日，费尼格仍未接受法官透露路易丝或迈克尔尸体位置的邀请。在宣判时，迈克尔·大卫大法官澄清说，他惩罚费尼格不是因为他未能完成这项请求，而是因为他犯下了最邪恶的罪行。“你的罪行给南澳大利亚社会带来的震惊和焦虑，是路易丝·贝尔的父母和家人所遭受的痛苦无法比拟的。我的判决的效力将是你肯定会在狱中度过余生。”迪特尔·费尼格因谋杀路易丝·贝尔被判处监禁35年且不得假释。
By the day of his sentencing on December 6, 2016, Fennig had not accepted the judge's invitation to reveal the location of Louise or Michael's bodies. Upon delivering his sentence, Justice Michael David clarified he was not punishing Fennig for failing to fulfill this request, but for committing the most evil of crimes. Quote, the shock and anxiety that your offense caused to the South Australian community cannot be compared to the distress that must have been suffered by the parents and family of Louise Bell. The effect of my sentence will be that you most certainly spend the rest of your days in jail. Dita Fennig was sentenced to 35 years in prison without parole for the murder of Louise Bell.
除了他因谋杀迈克尔·黑尔而正在服刑的刑期外，这使他的不得假释的狱中时间达到了60年。2018年5月，费尼格对他的定罪提出上诉，重申了他的DNA可能是通过与他女儿接触而意外转移到路易丝的睡衣上这一论点。他的律师保罗·夏曼辩称，没有证据证实DNA是如何被放在受害者衣服上的，并称针对他当事人的有罪判决在法律上是不安全且令人不满意的。夏曼请求将DNA与被定罪的绑架者罗曼·海因斯（Roman Hines）进行比对，海因斯最近因在2016年2月在盐溪（Salt Creek）绑架、残害和性侵两名外国背包客而被判处22年监禁。
In addition to the sentence he was already serving in relation to the murder of Michael Black, this brought his non-parole jail time to 60 years. In May 2018, Fennig appealed his conviction, reverting to the argument that his DNA could have been accidentally transferred to Louise's pajama top via contact with his daughter. His lawyer Paul Charmon argued there was no evidence to confirm how the DNA was placed on the victim's clothing and called the guilty verdict against his client, legally unsafe and unsatisfactory. Charmon requested the DNA be tested against convicted kidnapper Roman Hines, who had recently been sentenced to 22 years in jail for abducting,
像费尼格一样，海因斯也有德国血统，并在20世纪80年代住在贝尔住宅附近。上诉被驳回，费尼格的无期徒刑得以维持。费尼格被定罪的消息在南澳大利亚引发了轩然大波，居民们反思了该案在过去三十年中对社会产生的影响。路易丝的一位表亲向媒体讲述了这场悲剧如何影响了他的生活。尽管他的表妹失踪时他只有六岁，但他解释说：“我在它的阴影下长大。我对我的孩子过度保护。我一直装着卷帘。我一直养着狗。你总是会想，怎么会有人做出这种事？怎么会有人能逃脱谋杀？你会想是否也会有人来抓你。”
brutalising and sexually assaulting two foreign backpackers in Salt Creek in February 2016. Like Fennig, Hines also had a German ancestry and had lived in proximity to the Bell residence in the 1980s. The appeal was denied and Fennig's life sentence was upheld. News of Fennig's convictions sparked shockwaves across South Australia, as residents reflected on the impact the case had on society over the past three decades. One of Louise's cousins spoke to the media about how the tragedy had impacted his life. Despite being just six years old when his cousin went missing, he explained, I grew up in the shadow of it. I'm overprotective with my children. I've always had roller shutters.
他的这种看法得到了无数其他人的共鸣，他们在路易丝1983年失踪所造成的恐惧和偏执的笼罩下长大，这被称为一个转折点，从此家庭更加意识到要锁好门窗，并采取更严格的防范措施来保护儿童，即使在自己家中也是如此。副警察专员格兰特·史蒂文斯解释说：“当一个孩子被带走时，我们会看着我们自己的家庭，并想知道我们自己的孩子到底有多安全。我们希望这样的事情永远不会影响到我们的家庭或我们亲近的人。它直击那些基本原则的核心，即一个人的家就是他的城堡，你有权在那里感到安全。”
I've always owned a dog. You always just thought, how could someone do this? How could someone get away with murder? And you'd wonder if someone would come to take you as well. His sentiment was shared by countless others who grew up under the blanket of fear and paranoia created by Louise's 1983 disappearance, which has been described as a turning point in which families became more conscious of locking their doors and windows and taking more stringent precautions to protect their children, even within their own homes. Deputy Police Commissioner Grant Stevens explained, When a child is taken, we look at our own families and we wonder just how safe our own kids are. And we hope that something like this never affects our family or people we
阿德莱德大学法学院犯罪学讲师艾伦·佩里（Alan Perry）博士在1984年接受州际报纸《悉尼先驱晨报》采访时，描述了他在发生在全州的针对儿童和青少年的犯罪激增后，在阿德莱德居民身上注意到的文化转变。佩里博士称：“1973年的阿德莱德是一个轻松、开放的城市。人们把汽车停在街上不锁门，晚上也会敞开前门不锁。它真的就像一个大乡村小镇。在10年里，生活质量发生了显著恶化。人们变得恐惧、防备、猜疑。我不知道现在还有谁敢晚上不锁前门睡觉。这是一种态度的改变，而不是地方的改变。这是最让人悲伤的方面。阿德莱德变了。它失去了它的纯真。一旦你失去了它，它就永远失去了。”
are close to. It cuts to the core of those basic principles that a man's home is his castle, and you have a right to feel safe there. Dr. Alan Perry, a criminology lecturer within the law faculty at the University of Adelaide, spoke to Interstate newspaper The Sydney Morning Herald in 1984 and described the cultural shift he noticed in Adelaide residents following the spade of crimes committed against children and teens that occurred throughout the state. Dr. Perry, quote Adelaide was a relaxed, open city in 1973. People left their cars unlocked on the street and would leave their front doors unlocked at night. It really was just a big country town. In 10 years, there has been a considerable deterioration in the quality of life. People
由迪特尔·费尼格故意放在班克格罗夫前草坪上的睡衣上衣，仍然是将他直接与谋杀路易丝·贝尔联系起来的唯一DNA证据。在9频道名为《邪恶之城》（City of Evil）的电视剧中，阿德莱德报纸《广告人报》（The Advertiser）的调查记者奈杰尔·亨特（Nigel Hunt）说：“讽刺有时是一件美妙的事情。早在1983年，竟然是费尼格本人给了警方如此关键的证据，这太不可思议了。”截至2019年初，路易丝·贝尔和迈克尔·黑尔仍未被找到。对他们遗骸的搜寻仍在继续。本集尚无评论。点击字幕中的任何句子即可发表评论。
have become fearful, defensive, suspicious. I don't know anyone who goes to bed with the front door unlocked now. It's a changing attitude rather than a change in the place. That is the saddest aspect. Adelaide has changed. It has lost its innocence. And once you lose it, it's lost forever. The pajama top intentionally placed by Dieter Fenig on the front lawn at underbank Grove remains the only piece of DNA evidence directly connecting him to the murder of Louise Bell. During a Channel 9 television series titled City of Evil, Nigel Hunt, an investigative reporter for Adelaide newspaper, the advertiser said, quote, irony can be a wonderful thing. The fact that it was Fenig himself that gave police such a vital
变得恐惧、防备、多疑。我不知道现在还有谁睡觉时不反锁前门。这是一种态度的改变，而不是地方本身的改变。这才是最让人难过的一面。阿德莱德变了。它失去了纯真。一旦你失去了它，就永远失去了。迪特尔·费尼格故意放在安德班克格罗夫前草坪上的睡衣上衣，仍然是将他直接与路易斯·贝尔谋杀案联系起来的唯一DNA证据。在阿德莱德报纸《广告人报》的调查记者奈杰尔·亨特参与的名为《邪恶之城》的第九频道电视系列节目中，他曾引述说：“讽刺有时是一件美妙的事情。1983年，费尼格本人竟然向警方提供了如此至关重要的
piece of evidence way back in 1983 is extraordinary. As of early 2019, Louise Bell and Michael Black have never been found. The search for their remains continues. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
证据，这真是非同寻常。”截至2019年初，路易斯·贝尔和迈克尔·布莱克的遗体仍未被找到。寻找他们遗体的搜寻工作仍在继续。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。